Now,
what did you wear in terms of like a base
layer and we was there concerned about
you sweating while you're
pulling all that weight,
especially initially
when it was 375 pounds.
Yeah. So you know, one of the
famous lines that, you know,
people who have been in the
polar environments will say
is if you sweat, you die.
Um,
and you know,
it's maybe a little bit of hyperbole
but it's not far from the truth,
which is you start sweating and
you stop for even 30 seconds.
You're clothes are literally
freezing to your body.
And so it was this crazy kind of kind of
balance of being able to pull this sled,
get your heart rate elevated enough to
keep your body warm but not too warm that
you were sweating.
And so any second I would start sweating,
I would strip layers off. So there was
times, especially when there was no wind,
it's still be ambient temperature minus
20 minus 25 but I would just have like a
thin gore tex jacket on and
one base layer. That's it.
I mean, we were in Marino.
I Marino actually itches my skin,
although it's really good, but for me,
I'm a little bit allergic to it.
Um, so I work synthetic fabric.
Did they have a synthetic that completely
mimics Marino in terms of the way it,
when it's moist,
you still stay warm?
Yeah. So mark, Marina, I honestly, Marino
is amazing fabric for that reason. Um,
unfortunately for me, like
I said, it just gets weird.
Tastes my skin.
So funny that you could suffer,
can't have clothes on,
maybe feel that.
Uh, no, but, uh, so I used a
synthetic, but it's causing me,
are you using like w w what I was using,
mountain hardware base layers
and then actually my outer layer,
so is this Norwegian company called
Bergen's of Norway. They don't sponsor me,
but they actually,
believe it or not,
the Norwegians know a thing or two
about being in the polar environment.
And so they've designed a really good
jacket and pant that sexually really
breathable and really good. And then I
suit sewed a for rough, uh, onto the edge.
So a wolf, a wolf, uh, s, uh, for
rough on the outer side of the hood.
I think it's Wolffia. Wolfer will for
thought you were saying Whoa, whoa.
And I was like, it sounds like wolf,
you know more about this than me.
I'm not the output. All of
know your audience. I have not,
I have not a big hunter
myself. I've never, never had
had done that, a lot of that.
But uh, yeah, that's a wolfer
well, they, they know how to
survive in the cold. Yeah, exactly.
So the base layer is a synthetic. What
is the material that it's made out of?
The base layer is, yeah, to think it's a
synthetic. I'm like a poly polypropylene
so that when it sweats, it
dries quickly. Is it your idea?
Yeah. So it sweats. It dries quickly,
but the idea was just to not get it wet,
so basically stripped down
as much as possible. Um,
but like literally I'd go from that and
then of course I needed to eat and drink
every, whatever, 30 minutes
or whatever, actually more
like every hour. So I'd stop.
So I'd stop in the front of my sled.
I had a huge puffy down jacket,
like a massive like Michelin man,
huge puffy down jacket.
So even if you're stopping for a minute
to drink water before even trying to do
that, boom, put the big jacket on because
that's how cold or how cold you can get
immediately from stopping.
I mean,
it's just so much colder
than when pulling the sled.
Your heart rate stays up
and keeps you pretty warm.
I would imagine like your,
your hands and your feet to that would
be a real issue, right? The small digits.
Yeah. I mean, you know, frostbites
real for sure. Um, hands of the gloves.
That's why some of this stuff I was doing
in the training of get my hands with a
dexterity. You know, you'd have to tie all
these knots with big gloves, mittens on.
You can't take your gloves off for
any sizable period of time. Uh,
if you look back on a lot of my photos,
I've actually got tape on my face
over across my nose and my cheeks.
And that's because I started getting
tiny little bits of frostbite on the
bottoms of my nose and on,
on my cheeks because I'd wear a full
face mask buff everything but even tiny
little, you know, one, you know,
needle prick of wind on
your face throughout the day
and that cold it's going to
turn into a cold injury. And so I started
getting a few cold injuries on my face.
Nothing, you know, too bad
you're looking at Greece,
your face up or anything like
mostly the, the tape. Um,
and then so I had a little bit of like
Vaseline or like chapstick type of stuff
on some of the batteries.
The one thing actually that I
did that I'd never done before,
we'd actually worked when
I was a tip that I got,
which was my fingers started cracking
really, really bad from the cold.
And so they were like really
painful and I actually was pouring,
putting super glue into all of those.
Basically little micro cuts on my fingers,
which when someone told me that
as a trick, I was like, really?
But turns out it's actually
a really good trick.
So that's kind of super gluing these
cuts on my fingers back together. Um,
and that actually worked reasonably
well. I'll things kids. I mean,
I was all things considered is
the operative word, but yeah. Wow.
So you're wearing the, what
about your eyes? So I'm wearing,
I'm wearing a goggles. Um, but
you know, funny enough, you know,
I had a couple of, uh, you know, fancier,
nicer ski goggles with me. Um, but yeah,
there's the tape on my face right
there. Uh, but, uh, but yeah, it's like,
that's actually just
like the normal KT tape,
like a physio tape that you'd
see like athletes wearing.
And I just had it in my repair kit.
It wasn't meant for this purpose,
but I was like,
what do I have that I could put on my
face to block it a little bit better? Um,
but I had those goggles on
some of the time, but actual,
the goggle that I wore the most was one
that you would might use for motocross.
Um,
because it has like a plastic face mask
over the front of it cause the wind when
it was blowing,
it would just kind of blow around.
So sometimes I had this flea stripped
over my face, but it blow too much. Um,
and so I had this more plastic face
mass gas. So that's, that's the,
that's when you could see lookout
frozen. It's frozen. It is on the inside.
Oh my God, man. There. And then
like this neoprene mask underneath.
So I had like double faced back double
tape, like anything to just, you know,
keep me,
keep me warm.
Suspected that it was so high
above sea level there. Yeah. Yeah.
So you've got whatever it is,
9,000, 300 feet at the South Pole.
So it's basically just like
elevated ground, but it
seems flat. Right. But yeah,
I started at sea level,
so I'm not only add like how much are
you going uphill all the way to the south
coast for the first 40 sub days,
I pulled that sled up hill completely,
so it was,
think freaks me out.